Your plan of attack and reasoning for
changing the fire based
schema sounds good.
So, I give you my blessing
to implement buy and un-buy.
In the end you should
have this functionality,
where the style changes as seen here.
If the item's bought it
should be crossed out and
it should say who it was bought by.
If it was bought by you it
should simply say Bought by You.
If it was bought by another user,
say the user's name right here.
Now if the item hasn't been bought yet,
you shouldn't see a strike through, and
you should also still
see this trashcan icon
which allows you to remove the item.
Items that have already been
bought can't be removed.
One final note, you should only be able
to unbuy an item that you've bought.
If Kagure says that she bought some jam,
Walter should not either by mistake or
on purpose, be able to un-buy
that jam she just bought.
Only Kagure should be able to un-buy
an item in case her figure strayed and
she bought it buy accident or
something else happened.
Okay so makes sense?
All right, well I'm sending
over the spec right now and
I'll check back in with
you in a little bit.